the cow died religion and unusual blend
of eastern and western faiths appears to
be flourishing in Vietnam across the
country there are almost 400 temples
followers worship openly but it wasn't
always that way I've been offered an
audience with Cao Dai senior Cardinal
income done to understand the religion
sub secretive history how do you do that
very pleased to meet you can you give me
a brief history of the religion oh yeah
all right
the purpose of catechism is to unite the
traditions of all religions in the world
a girl died tourism was established in
Vietnam in 1926 and Vietnam at that time
was under the control of the French
administration I understood that some of
your leaders were imprisoned by the
French is that so
there was some misunderstanding between
the French and terrorism at a time when
all the little was arrested and sent in
exile for five years but after that when
they understood the purpose of this
religion the French administration
alleged his holiness to be returned into
Vietnam
but Cao Dai struggles did not end with
the French in 1943 they took up arms
against Japanese invaders the count died
army established a semi-autonomous state
in the Mekong Delta that survived for a
decade after the Japanese left when the
Communists took control of Vietnam in
1975 coward Azam was banned for more
than two decades it wasn't just because
the government feared colonize military
history or its blending of faith from
all over the world it was also because
of the secret ceremony that lay at the
heart of the religion and our leaders
thought the father divided himself into
other beings and those people went out
to us and they become mediums so those
mediums were used to establish the
religion those mediums received a
message from God to establish and write
our religious regulations the
Constitution's
and now we use those at the basis of how
they ISM the details of what happened in
these sailors is still secret known only
by high dignitaries what is known is
that there were always two mediums
controlling some sort of instrument
someone to read the instrument and the
secretary to write down the message when
the Vietnamese government made it legal
to practice the coyote religion in 1997
one of the conditions was that seances
would remain banned
[Music]
you